-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week where I send out
a hashtag, and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic,
so this week I sent out a
hashtag, #DescribeAMovieBadly.
And I asked you guys
to take a movie
and just give it
a funny or weird summary.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love that.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"Describe a movie badly"
responses from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one
is from @HighNeckEnt.
-Mm.
High neck?
-High neck --
You think he's like
an ears, nose,
and throat doctor?
-Maybe. I hope so.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @ThrewRedButter.
[ Laughter ]
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from
@taradublinrocks.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
That is correct!
♪♪
-That's not even badly.
That's perfectly.
-That's actually perfect.
Yeah, exactly.
This one's from
@RyanBartholomee.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Spoiler alert!
-This is from @ohwhelm?
-Oh, whelm.
-Whelm?
Like overwhelmed, maybe?
-No, o-h.
Oh, whelm.
-Oh, whelm.
Like "Oh, well"?
-Maybe they think "Oh, well --"
Yeah, they added --
They changed it up,
and they added an "m" to it.
-It's classy.
-Yeah.
It is, right?
-Yeah -- "Oh, whelm."
"Whom are you talking to?"
-Oh, are you not educated?
I went to --
-Educated University.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I went
to the College of Education,
the University of
the College of Education.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, whelm.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
OhWhelm, he says...
-Hey!
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Marty!"
-This one's from @NickDigs.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yes.
Exactly right.
This one's from @JessiDiPette.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did you ever hear that joke --
how do you know
if a shark loves you?
-How?
-♪ Da-na ♪
♪ Da-na ♪
♪ Da-na, da-na,
da, na da da ♪
♪ Da, na da, da na ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-Appreciate it. Thank you.
Not bad, right?
-Wow!
-I likes.
-Thank you.
-Wow, nice!
-This one's from --
-Wow! Wait a second.
I got to take that one in.
-No, we're moving on.
-Hold on, hold on.
My brain is over -- oh whelm'd.
-Gotta let that marinate, man.
That was genius.
-This one's from -- thank you.
It's from @MarisaRosie22.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It sounds heartwarming.
[ Applause ]
This one's funny.
It's from @ghost7.
They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ah, that's funny.
This one's just --
You got to read this one.
This one's from @fatherkasey.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Right.
He's not da friend.
-No, he's not da friend.
Last one's from @rockinsean84.
He says...
There you have it right there.
[ Laughter ]
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.